hey guys in this video we're going to talk about
how to stop gallbladder pain okay there's two
steps one is an acupressure technique and the
other is kind of correcting why you have the
pain in the first place now you can apply this if
you have your gallbladder out or if you still have
your gall better okay now the instant pain
relief is your gallbladder is on the right
side it's right here it's underneath the right
ribcage hanging down like maybe an inch or two
on the right side about an inch or two to the
mitt from the midline right about here okay so
what you want to do is you don't want to press
over the gallbladder you want to press on the
opposite side over here so you want to press on
the pancreas this organ so if you actually put
your finger over your gallbladder and press on
the opposite side which is the mirror image side
one inch down below the ribcage two inches to
the left side you're going to press in this one
spot right through and here you're going to find
a really tender spot on the opposite side that the
gallbladder is in and you're going to press on
that and work that out for like a minute or two
and find a little bit of a knot and you're going
to get instant relief on your gallbladder okay
so this is a great way to eliminate the pain
from post surgery it's also to give you some
temporary relief even if you have a gallstone
but do not press on the gallbladder if you have
pain in the gallbladder press on the opposite
mirror image side and the way you know you get
the exact spot is it'll be very tender okay go
light and just kind of massage it okay so that's
how you get rid of the pain now if you have a
stone you're going to have to watch my video
on how to dissolve stones you're going to need
purified bile salts I put a link down there of
what could take if you have stone because it helps
dissolve it stones come from a lack of bile and
you need to take purified bile salts but you know
let's say you don't have stones you just have
pain or we have the gallbladder out and it just
never got better here's some things you need to
do you need to reduce of course all this sugar
in the diet you have to get the sugar out and
the refined grains grains breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes all these
things will really add surveyed the gallbladder in
fact that's a started my gallbladder problem and
if you combine the grain with meat or protein you
really aggravate the gallbladder I'll never forget
in college I made some meatloaf and I didn't
know you had to drain the grease so here I put
a whole bunch of bread whole bunch of meat with
a whole bunch of saturated fat we'll talk about
to catch up and I ate that whole thing right
before bed big mistake wake up at two o'clock
in the morning and I am in serious pain and of
course I had no connection between that in two
weeks later because my awareness is very low but
you want to get rid of the sugar get rid of the
grains and reduce fat especially not certain nuts
especially walnuts and other nuts and even peanuts
will aggravate the gallbladder okay and it's
going to shoot pain sometimes up on the right
side here or the shoulder blade on the right
side so you want to get rid of lower your fast
and also nuts and then if you eat less frequently
you will actually decrease insulin it will give a
chance for the gallbladder to concentrate back
up because the gallbladder concentrates bile
so if you're eating too many frequent meals then
you never have enough file so everything you just
get always this constant incomplete digestion
and because you don't have enough file so like
three meals with no snacks would be great and
even two meals ok choline is a supplement that
you can buy at the health and store that will
help the gall bladder it helps relax the gallbladder
it helps drain things from the liver
and then kale kale and all the cruciferous vegetables but I like kale the best you can do a
kale shake for the link down there is really good
for the gallbladder pain because those factors
and those vegetables help dislodge and loosen up
any sludge in the gallbladder and lastly purified
bile salts I mentioned that before that will
help take the bloating out in the pain into the
link down below thank you so much for watching